الصحه النفسيه في مكان العمل جمله تحمل
الكثير من التساؤلات عن صحتنا النفسيه
اثناء اداء اعمالنا وتاثير بيئات العمل
على الموظفين سلبا وايجابا الامر الذي دعى
مؤسسه تهون والمركز السعودي لتعزيز الصحه
النفسيه الى اجراء دراسه بهذا الخصوص داخل
السعوديه الدراسه شملت اربعه الاف موظف
وموظفه في القطاعين العام والخاص في
السعوديه وتوصلت الى عده نتائج من ابرزها
ان اربعه من كل خمسه موظفين وجهوا عارضا
واحدا على الاقل مرتبطا بالصحه النفسيه
خلال العام الماضي 20 22 22
34% من الموظفين يشعرون انهم لا يحصلون
على التقدير الكافي فيما يعتقد سبعه 57%
من الموظفين انهم يتعرضون للضغط العصبي في
مكان العمل وسته 36% من الموظفين اكدوا
انهم يرضونا للحد الادنى من التنمر ومن
النتائج اللافته مشاهدينا ان 82% من
المؤسسات لا تخصص اي ميزانيه لمعالجه مساء
المرتبطه بالصحه النفسيه لموظفيها ما هي
الاعراض النفسيه الاكثر شيوعا لدى
الموظفين في المؤسسات السعوديه
52% من الموظفين وجهوا الاحتراق الوظيفي
لما يتعرضوا 46% منهم لقلق بشكل متكرر
واخيرا الضغط العصبي في تعرض له ثمانيه
وثلاثون في المئه من الموظفين اثناء
ممارسه الاعمال اليوم
هل انت منفتح على الحديث عن صحتك النفسيه
في مكان عملك مع زملائك او المديرين سؤال
تم طرحه في هذه الدراسه
37% من الذين شاركوا في الدراسه مستعدون
للحديث عن صحتهم النفسيه بالرغم من تحفظ
الاناث خصوصا على هذه الخطوه
العلاج النفسي هذا الحديث ادخال حياك
خليني اسالك لماذا هذه الدراسه فعليه ان
هي تشخص واقع الصحه النفسيه في يعني بين
الموظفين والموظفات في السعوديه
يعني اخذنا بالاعتبار انه العينه شمله
4000 موظفه طبعا مثل الدراسه هذه مثل
الدراسه هذه تعتبر من الدراسات القليله
سواء على المستوى
العربي او المستوى المحلي همم
جبناها انا تركنت اشر على على السماعه بس
انا كنت احكي على انه هذه الدراسه لاي مدى
هي فعليا تشخص واقع الصحه النفسيه عندنا
بمعنى انه هذه 4000 عينه هي اللي شملتها
هذه الدراسه فهل ممكن ناخذ هذه الارقام
وهذه الدراسه بانها واقعيه فعلا للي
قاعدين نعيش اليوم
دائما الدراسات بتعطينا عينه تعطينا
مؤشرات على ما يحدث داخل المجتمع الدراسه
الاكبر
فمثل هذه الدراسه نستطيع ان ناخذ نستطيع
ان نقول انها تعطينا همم رؤيه تعطينا همم
اساس للانطلاق من خلال النظر الى مستويات
الصحه النفسيه في بيئات العمل المختلفه
سواء على المستوى القطاع الخاص او القطاع
من المسؤول عن الصحه النفسيه للموظفين في
المؤسسات بطبيعه الحل المؤسسات في حداد هي
المسؤوله لانها لابد ال- ال- لتوفير
المساله الصحه النفسيه او موضوع عن الصحه
النفسيه للعاملين فيها همم تحتاج الى
قرارات من اصحاب العمل الحداد هم يعني
المسؤولين في هذه الجهات المختلفه لانها
لن تكون همم مجانيه لابد ان تكون همم على
همم
تكون بشراهه مع جهات متخصصه في المجال ال-
ال- النفسي سواء كانت هذه المراكز حكوميه
مراكز خاصه تقدم مثل هذه الخدمات الخدمات
هذه ربما تكون خدمات وقائيه همم خدمات همم
تثقيفيه بالاضافه الى الخدمات العلاجيه
عندما يصاب افراد هذه الجهات ببعض المشاكل
الممتازه من النتائج
الملفته انه 82% من المؤسسات اصلا مش
مخصصه اي ميزانيه لمعالجه هذه المسائل
المسائل همم الصحه النفسيه وغيرها تشوف
انه طبيعي
قصور قصور في الجهات نفسها في معرفه مدى
اهميه اصلا همم الصحه النفسيه للموظف او
للعامل في الجهه ومدى واثار هذه الصحنه
النفسيه على انتاجيه الموظف في حداد لانه
همم اعتقد انه كثير من ال- ال- ال- الجهات
سواء كانت المؤسسات الحكوميه او العامه
خاصه تتاثر في مستوى صحه افرادها كل ما
كانت الافراد الاول العاملين في هذه
الجهات يتمتعون في صحه نفسيه عاليه
بالاضافه الى خلوهم من المشكله همم
النفسيه بالاضافه الى الضغوط همم المختلفه
كل ما كان اثر على الانتاجيه واثر على
العمل بشكل عام وعلى النتائج التي يستطيع
انه ال ال المسؤولين انهم يلمسونها خلال
فتره او خلال العمل في هذه القطاعات
المختلفه احنا عندنا مشكله في موضوع
الحديث عن الصحه النفسيه بمعنى انه همم هل
في انفتاح على الحديث في هذا الموضوع من
الجنسين انا اتحدث عن الذكر وعن همم
الانثى ويمكن اساسا اللي كان موجود في هذه
الدراسه همم انه بالرغم من تحفظ الاناء
طبعا خصوصا على هذه الخطوه فاحنا لدينا
37% من من شارك في هذه الدراسه مستعد دول
الحديث عن صحه النفسيه فقط سبعه
او همم 37
63% همم لا يرغبون وهذه نسبه كبيره همم
انا اعتقد هي ثقافه اا عامه وليست ثقافه
خاصه في العاملين فقط
وبالاضافه الى مساله الوصمه همم
الاجتماعيه في مساله
انك تتكلم مثلا عن انك تصاب بمشكلات نفسيه
او اضطرابات النفسيه بالاضافه الى مفهوم
الاضطراب النفسيه عندنا اللي هو المشكله
اللي يعتقد دائما الشخص المصاب في المرض
النفسي دائما يتعرض الى وصف اجتماعيه قد
تؤدي فيه الى انه يبتعد عن الاخرين همم
يشعر بالتقدير اقل من الاخر الان لو قلنا
انه 80% مثلا من همم من الموظفين الموظفات
في السعوديه حسب مثلا هذه الدراسه يعانون
على الاقل من من اضطراب مثلا نفسي او من
مشكله وجهها او من غيرها بالتالي لاي ماده
احنا ممكن نواجه مشكله الاحتراق الوظيفه
وتصبح فعليا تحتاج لعلاج
صحيح
الاغلب ال ال العاملين سواء في القطاع
العام او القطاع الخاص هم يتعرضون
للاحتراق الوظيفي اذا لم تكن هذه الجهات
التي يعملون فيها تهتم في الجانب النفسي
فلا بد في ال ال ال المحصله ان يحصل
احتراق وظيفه لدى العاملين فيها لماذا
لانه الجانب الوقائي الان متى تكون صحيح
نفسيا عندما تكون لديك المهارات ولديك
الامكانيات في التعامل مع الضغوطات التي
تواجه وهذه لابد ان تتعرض لها سواء على
مستوى الشخصي او على المستوى العملي
وبالتالي اذا الجهات التي انا اعمل فيها
بالاضافه الى همم الشخص نفسه لا يستطيع ان
يتعامل مع مثل هذه الضغوط فلا بد ان يتعرض
الى مشكلات ربما تكون على علاقه في الاسره
كذلك وبالتالي ستعود على ايضا همم ايضا
سوف تؤثر على
العمل شكرا